the world around us is a fascinating
place
and it is not confined to our planet
what we see around
is just a tiny part of the entire cosmos
and to date terrestrial spacecraft have
been able to reach
only as far as the limits of the solar
system i
invite you to set out on a journey which
will start with the voyager's
trajectories
continue around the closest stars and
end in the infinite depths of our
universe
our trip is going to be swift absorbing
and really enthralling please make
yourselves comfortable
and let's begin
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
during this long time span the voyagers
have taken detailed photographs of
jupiter and saturn
as well as their satellites uranus was
closely studied
and its 11 moons were discovered thanks
to the voyager mission
[Music]
it's the pictures taken by voyager 2
that allowed scientists to be able to
see one of the most controversial bodies
in the solar system miranda uranus's
satellite
the subject of big space travel was
first broached in 1966
gary flandreau still a student published
a scientific paper
where he predicted the orbits of jupiter
saturn uranus and neptune
getting closer together by the late
1970s
the predictions proved to be accurate on
the 10th of march
1982 a full planetary parade took place
the eight planets of the solar system
and pluto were on the same side of the
sun
at the angle of 95 degrees the
rendezvous of the giant planets
provided opportunities for using
gravitational maneuvering to fly the two
apparatuses on the trajectories jupiter
saturn pluto
and jupiter uranus neptune
ten thousand possible trajectories were
considered when the program was being
worked out
before the two of them were finally
agreed upon
apart from exploring furthermost objects
of the solar system
the voyagers have taken a great number
of photos of our own planet
including one of the most well-known
ones from a record distance of almost
6 billion kilometers
the idea of the picture as well as its
name the pale blue dot
belongs to a prominent astrophysicist of
the 20th century
and an outstanding popularizer of
science carl
sagan the scientists didn't rule out the
possibility of the voyagers and
countering extraterrestrial beings
that is why both spacecraft carried a
gold-plated audio visual disk
with greetings in 55 different languages
significant scientific data views of the
earth and its position in relation to
its 14 pulses
music holds a special place in the
message to intelligent aliens
the collection of music includes
classical works by bach
mozart beethoven pieces by lewis
armstrong and chuck berry
as well as folk music from around the
world
the record also contains an instruction
on how to access the data
on its back however let us not dwell on
the past
but look at the future of the voyager
project
where are the spacecraft now and what
awaits
these solitary space wanderies
the voyager's chief mission exploration
of furthermost
planets in the solar system was
completed long ago
now the main objective of both probes is
studying transitive areas between the
sun
and interstellar plasma the voyagers
travel at 17.07 kilometers per second
and 15.64 kilometers per second
respectively
at the moment this video is posted the
distance between the earth and voyager 1
is approximately 21.7 billion kilometers
while voyager 2 is 17.9 billion
kilometers away from
us the spacecraft's missions
differ by their trajectory
voyager 1 flew only by jupiter and
saturn while voyager 2 went further
and flew by uranus and neptune as well
that is the reason why voyager 2 is
never going to catch up with its twin
brother
in 2012 voyager 1 left the heliosphere
boundaries
to cross into interstellar space
it follows a hyperbolic trajectory so
voyager 1
is not going to return to the solar
system due to the gravitational force of
the latter
its twin overcame the heliopause only in
november 2018
leaving the heliosphere does not
actually mean leaving the solar system
to do this one has to go as far as the
oort cloud
a hypothetical region of the solar
system and a place of birth of
ice comets only there will the gravity
force of our star
become negligibly feeble the voyagers
are powered by plutonium-238
radioisotope thermoelectric generators
after 42 years the power of the probes
went down to 55
and is now 249 watt as opposed to 470
watt
at the time of launch this does not
allow full application of the probe's
scientific equipment
only 5 out of 10 devices are operating
now
the cosmic ray system the low energy
charged particle instrument
the magnetometer the plasma wave
subsystem and the plasma instrument
now the voyager mission members are
struggling to maintain the equipment's
operation
according to preliminary estimates the
minimal energy generation required for
scientific studies
will be sustained till 2025.
this time is hoped to be sufficient to
explore interstellar space
in particular the structure of the
heliopause
in the future the data may be used in
planning missions to the stellar system
closest to us
alpha centauri by about
2030 the probes will switch into a radio
beacon mode
and will transmit the last signal to the
earth in 2036
thus the life expectancy of the voyages
will reach about 59 years
one must admit it is quite a period for
a space trip
in about 300 years voyager 2 is going to
reach the inner edge of the oort cloud
and will completely leave it only in 30
000 years
according to the data provided by the
hubble telescope
it will take voyager 2 approximately 2
000 years to cross the gas cloud
in which the solar system floats it will
take the probe about 90
000 years to get into other interstellar
clouds
the remains of the voyages are presumed
to reach stars as well
in about 40 000 years voyager 1 is
supposed to pass
glieser 445 as star and camel apartalis
within a 1.6 light years distance
meanwhile its twin will approach ross
as star and andromeda at 1.7 light years
distance
in 290 000 years
voyager 2 will fly by serious at a 4.3
light-years distance life-sustaining
planets
are unlikely to exist in the vicinity of
either ross 248
or gliese 445 both of them are red
dwarfs
each of them hardly half the mass of the
sun
ros 248 is notable for being a flare
star
that is one that spontaneously flares up
at about the time voyager 2 approaches
ross 248
closest the closest star to the sun
will for a short time be ros 248
and not proxima centauri the voyagers
are to remain eternal wanderers
in the universe they won't be able to
leave the milky way
and are destined to wander around our
galaxy
they have lived through scores of
failures on their journey
but in spite of that they continue to
operate
transmitting important scientific data
to the earth
with the initially planned five-year
lifespan they're pushing their
fourth decade of service as far as i'm
concerned
the voyager project is the most
successful idea
in the history of space exploration the
data received during the mission
have changed man's perception of the
solar system
it is hard to tell whether an
extraterrestrial race will ever read the
message on the golden plated discs
on the voyages since the solar system is
15 times
faster than the voyages it's circling
around the galaxy center
it is possible that our planet will
recapture the remains of the probes
in some hundreds of millions of years
maybe
the message aimed at aliens will
eventually be a greeting from a distant
past
to the human race of the future
[Music]
man's life has changed significantly
when we learned to use optical devices
for research
410 years has passed since the time when
galileo galilei
pointed a three-power spyglass at the
moon
and just 29 years since the launch of
hubble
the first space observatory today the
distance to the edge of the observable
universe
equals approximately 14 billion parsecs
and this may well be called just the
beginning of our exploration
it is interplanetary space probes that
are going to herald the next stage
the most famous ones like the voyages or
new horizons
are known worldwide but among spacecraft
like these
there are veterans as well one of them
is the cassini interplanetary orbiter
which started its mission back in 1997
and completed it quite recently what did
the spacecraft discover
and what did it get to observe in the 20
years of its historic mission
originally the cassini project implied
exploring saturn and its satellites
and delivering the huygens huygenslander
to titan
the project was made real by the efforts
of several organizations
including nasa esa the italian space
agency
and others about 260 scientists
from 17 countries were involved with the
project
the huygenslander was created by the
european space agency
with a systems section produced by
lockheed martin specialists
one of nasa's departments was in charge
of the flight
the initial weight of the spacecraft was
5 tons
719 kilos its height was
6.7 meters and its width 4 meters
the 320 kilo probe 336 kilo scientific
instruments
and 3 310 kilos of fuel
all added to the impressive weight of
the spacecraft
cassini was powered by radio isotope
thermoelectric generators
using radioactive plutonium-238 for fuel
also the spacecraft had 12 scientific
instruments on board
among them a mass spectrometer an
ultraviolet radar
a magnetometer and others
the spacecraft was launched on october
the 15th
1997 from cape canaveral
in order to gain the desired speed the
spacecraft was initially flown in the
opposite direction from saturn
and passed venus twice then
in august 1999 cassini flew by the earth
at the speed of 69
000 kilometers per hour it used the
opportunity to test its cameras
and take a splendid picture of our
satellite
after this the biggest planet of the
solar system was awaiting it
jupiter which was passed by the
spacecraft on december the 30th
2000 cassini managed to take quite a
number of pictures of this planet
as well as a few of its satellites thus
providing substantial amount of
scientific data
including jupiter's atmospheric
circulation
as soon as on the 30th of june 2004 the
spacecraft reached saturn
and achieved its final goal by becoming
the planet's first artificial satellite
it was coasting at the orbital speed of
15 kilometers per second
the huygens probe onboard the cassini
spacecraft was supposed to take it from
there
on the 25th of december 2004 huygens
detached itself to set out on its
deliberate way to the surface of titan
even before cassini entered into orbit
around saturn
on the 14th of january 2005 the probe
penetrated the atmosphere of the
mysterious satellite
it touched down on a hard surface two
and a half hours later
in the following 72 minutes cassini
received signals from the probe on the
titan's surface
and beamed back 350 images to the earth
thanks to the data received it became
known that there were not only rivers
and lakes on titan
but rounded hydrocarbon pebbles and
methane clouds
cassini undertook further exploration of
the satellite
in the period of 13 years it flew by
saturn's largest satellite over a
hundred times
and stumbled upon a great number of
discoveries
the most fascinating of them was that
islands on titan's lakes
submerged and re-emerged however the
precise mechanism of this phenomenon
remains to be found out
during the time cassini was operating
astronomers from the earth discovered
seven new saturn satellites thanks to
the pictures transmitted from the
spacecraft
with the very first discoveries made
during the time cassini was approaching
saturn
saturn's new moons were dubbed pallini
polyduces and methony
while cassini remained in saturn's orbit
there were discovered satellites later
named
daphnis anthony aegean and the curious
satellite
s 2009 s1 which hasn't been given a name
yet
this satellite is the closest to its
planet speaking about the most
impressive discoveries made by cassini
two fascinating phenomena may be singled
out
these are rory and saturn's atmosphere
and an exciting hexagonal jet stream
with a red hurricane inside
soon after cassini's discovery of this
mysterious hexagon
another unaccountable property of the
vortex was registered by astronomers
with passing years the vortex changed
its color
the area of this hurricane is 50 times
that of the average hurricane
on the earth
[Music]
the next objective for exploration was
saturn's rings
it should be noted that some of them
like the anthi ark or the palini ring
were discovered by cassini itself
a number of finite details were revealed
by cassini as it observed the rings
for example how sharpened satellites
like daphnes kept cliff's watch on the
rings
and how a nice belt built up on them it
was also thanks to the casino mission
that it became known that there is a
water ocean
under the crust of enceladus just like
under the crust of some of jupiter's
satellites
this ocean might have the correct
chemistry for sustaining life
but unlike europa or ganymede the ocean
on enceladus
is possible for us to explore cassini
flew through its geeses a number of
times
the data received are soon going to be
used for creating devices for a new
mission to saturn
europa clipper
[Music]
in the 13 years cassini spent on
saturn's orbit
it received 635 gigabytes of data
and took almost half a million photos
before the spacecraft was launched only
18 of saturn's satellites were known to
scientists
in the seven years cassini was traveling
to saturn
13 more satellites were spotted
and during the spacecraft's operation 22
more
satellites were discovered seven of
which directly thanks to cassini's
pictures
today we know 82 satellites of this
planet
20 of them were discovered quite
recently
this makes saturn the richest planet and
satellites in the solar system
at the end of its mission cassini
discovered yet another surprising
phenomenon
a space between saturn's rings
just before the mission's grand finale
the spacecraft positioned itself between
rings
and instead of expected dust vortices it
observed just an absolutely empty space
cassini's fate was sealed in may 2017
due to the lack of fuel any further
operation of the spacecraft in orbit was
no longer possible
the missions management considered 19
options of the probe's destiny
one of them involved steering into orbit
around the sun or of one of saturn's
satellites but in the end it was decided
to let cassini burn up in the gas
giant's atmosphere
the decision was supposed to prevent the
saturn's satellite's possible biological
contamination
on the 22nd of april 2017
cassini performed a maneuver around
titan and found itself between
saturn and its closest train
the spacecraft kept taking pictures till
the very end
this is what its last photo beamed back
to the earth looked like
on entering the planet's atmosphere the
spacecraft pointed its aerial to the
earth
and began transmitting data about the
chemistry of saturnian atmosphere
soon after the connection with the
orbiter was lost it burned up in the
dense strata of saturnian atmosphere
even though the cassini mission wasn't
as tremendous as missions to mars
it proved extremely useful to
contemporary astronomy
the spacecraft brought scientists up to
speed with truly unique images on a
monthly basis
thanks to these many aspiring
astronomers built their careers
using this database the result of the
mission
indeed surpassed all expectations
because today we can realistically talk
about discovering life
on saturnian satellites perhaps we will
soon find
out about these discoveries and then it
will be perfectly clear
who to give credit for this
voyager 2 would never have made any of
its discoveries had it not been for
something that happened in the 1960s
that was to revolutionize our today's
perception of celestial bodies
in 1964 when gary flandreau then an
intern at nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory
started drawing graphs of planet's
future positions he soon found
that all the planets beyond the asteroid
belt were going to align in a very
narrow sector of the sky in the late
1970s
in our system this phenomenon occurs
once every 175 years
and this was a unique opportunity by
performing gravity boost maneuvers
a spacecraft would be able to whiz from
one planet to another
thus exploring them all it would also
reduce the time of the flight
which would greatly boost chances of
success
however due to potentially high costs
this ambitious project had to be
rejected
that's why nasa came up with something
different
in 1977 a cheaper project was planned
namely mariner jupiter saturn 77
even though the two probes were intended
to explore exclusively jupiter and
saturn
the scientists in charge of their
development designed the probes in a way
for them to be ready
for a prolonged journey the first
probe's trajectory
allowed it to additionally pass titan
one of saturn's moons with its own
atmosphere
as for the second spacecraft it was able
to fly by uranus and neptune
half a year before the planned launch it
was decided to change the project's name
thus the voyagers made their appearance
in the history of space discoveries
running ahead it should be mentioned
that in their long history
the voyagers have discovered a number of
phenomena whose existence was to be
confirmed only many years later
jupiter's tumultuous atmosphere
saturn's changeable rings and neptune's
dark spot
all these discoveries were made possible
thanks to the ambitious experiment
nasa's scientists ventured to carry out
nine years after its launch voyager 2
became the only spacecraft to ever reach
uranus
in order to boost up its connection with
the earth a 64 meter dsn antenna
and two 24 meter antennas were raid back
on our planet
the spacecraft's cameras were supposed
to be able to beam back several thousand
pictures
things we already knew about uranus
before the voyages approach
its rotation angle nine rings and five
of its satellites
the information scrupulously gleaned for
hundreds of years by the most prominent
minds of our planet
comprised a tiny portion of the
information that has been made available
today
thanks to that single swift flyby on the
7th of june 1985
the first navigation pictures of uranus
system were taken
but it was not until november the 6th
that the camera moved on to taking more
detailed images
it is quite extraordinary that the
magnetometers kept silent in november
december and even the first half of
january
at the same time the earth radiation
meter quietened down
only after the orbit of mars while
jupiter's radio emissions
persisted from the very day of the
launch michael kaiser from the goddard
space flight center
prophetically remarked it's either that
we've encountered a planet without a
magnetic field
or else it's so bizarre that we don't
know what to look for
thanks to the voyages investigations it
is now known that uranus's magnetic
field has some features
due to its peculiar rotation the
peculiarity lies in the fact that the
magnetic dipole does not coincide with
the planet's rotation axis
it is in fact displaced by one-third of
its radius relating to its center
besides the magnetic axis is tilted with
respect to the rotation axis at an angle
of 60 degrees
uranus's magnetosphere doesn't look like
a wide stripe
but is rather lopsided due to the strong
tilt of the rotation axis to the
magnetic axis
on the 27th of december 1985
uranus's latitudinal zones were clearly
visible in the transmitted images
dark brown at the poles and light to the
equator
on the same day thanks to the snapshots
steven sinnott was able to confirm the
discovery of uranus's first
unknown satellite 1985 u1
it was traditionally dubbed after a
character from a play by william
shakespeare
15 pug in the following several days
voyager 2 carried on taking pictures of
the moons
among them already known titania oberon
ariel umbriel and miranda
however their number grew threefailed
thanks to the pictures
on the 16th of january 1986
the voyager 2 project team announced the
discovery of six
more moons with the help of the photos
the largest objects 1986 u1 and u2
were discovered in the photos examined
on january the 3rd
u3 was discovered on january the 9th
and u4 u5 and u6 were registered on the
13th of january
the temporary designations of uranus's
satellites
were substituted by these up-to-date
names
12 porsche 11 juliet
9 cressida 13 rosalind 14 belinda
and 10 desdemona in the images of
january the 20th
some details of the relief on the
surface of oberon titania and dariel
were distinguishable
and two more satellites were discovered
on that day u7 and u8
six cordelia and seven ophelia on
january the 22nd
voyager 2 set off in its first flyby
program v751
in addition to taking regular snapshots
of the moons it captured the patchwork
of the uranian rings
and umbrella in color in one of the
images
taken on the following day bradford
smith found one more satellite
1986 u9
it was later dubbed eight bianca
miranda or rather its peculiar terrain
was a discovery that amazed nasa's
astrophysicists
it was possible to distinguish it thanks
to the voyages pictures
the outer layer of miranda's crust is
covered with crevices
dales cliffs and ravines which together
form a hybrid of geological features
from different worlds according to
explorer's estimates
at least 10 types of terrain find
themselves on a celestial body of a
measly 500 kilometers in diameter
after that it was time to discover
uranian rings
when voyager 2 was passing through the
planet's ring's plane
a great multitude of dusty particles
were observed 115 000 kilometers away
from the planet's core and sixty
thousand kilometers away from the outer
ring epsilon
it looked like a diffused nebula four
thousand kilometers thick
thus two new uranian rings were
discovered by voyager 2.
the first string was located between the
delta and epsilon ones
and was given the temporary designation
u1r in direct sunlight
it looked very narrow just about one or
two kilometers
and faint and only by using ultraviolet
detectors where astronomers able to
observe it
later uranus's tenth ring was seen in
the images
this picture shows all of them from the
bright epsilon ring to the faint line of
the sixth ring
the existence of the second drink
discovered by voyager 2
dubbed 1986 u2r was confirmed
only in 2004 it was located
39 500 kilometers away from the planet's
core
and within 20 years it had migrated
beyond
now finding itself within the distance
of up to 41
350 kilometers away from the core
before bidding farewell to uranus and
faring onward towards new horizons
voyager 2 took its last snapshot of the
planet
at the moment when this picture was
taken the probe was already a million
kilometers away and was making for yet
another mystery of the solar system
neptune this encounter would herald a
major scientific breakthrough
at the same time billions of kilometers
away
thousands of people held their breath in
anticipation of yet another step
into the unknown
this was the famous voyager 2 probe
which still remains the only apparatus
to have flown by neptune
voyager 2 spent just a few months near
the planet
but even in that short time span it was
able to get a great amount
of valuable information neptune was the
last
big object to be seen by voyager 2
before the probe entered the heliopour's
boundaries
and came into interstellar space
but what did the last shots from neptune
look like
before you find out what it was let's
look at the probe's history
august the 20th 1977
this is the day when voyager 2 left the
surface of the earth
41 years later it was to go beyond the
boundaries
of the entire solar system initially
its mission implied only the exploration
of jupiter
saturn and their satellites but the
flight's trajectory presented the
opportunity of flying by uranus and
neptune as well
as soon as on july the 9th 1979
voyager 2 was 71 000 kilometers away
from jupiter
the probe also flew by its satellites
europa and ganymede
the images received from the spacecraft
gave grouse for putting forward the
hypothesis of there being a liquid ocean
under the crust of europa the
observation of ganymede showed that it
was covered by a dirty ice crust
by the time two more years had elapsed
voyager 2 was 101 000 kilometers away
from saturn
the probe flew by its satellites tethers
and enceladus
and transmitted detailed pictures of
their surface
according to initial forecasts that was
supposed to be the end of its mission
but voyager 2 continued on its course
january the 24th 1986
the spacecraft approached uranus and
passed it at the distance of 81
000 kilometers voyager 2 sent a number
of photos to the earth
the planet's satellites as well as its
rings and surface were to be seen in the
pictures
it is thanks to them that two more
uranus's rings were discovered
and the nine already known ones were
studied closer
two more years later voyager 2 found
itself in the vicinity of the
furthermost
object of its mission and passed neptune
within 48 000
kilometers on august 24 1989
it was able to take unique photographs
of this giant
and shoot triton its largest satellite
active geezers were discovered on triton
which came as a big surprise
given the remote position and low
temperature of this celestial body
only 21 years after that did the probe
cross the termination shock
and entered the heliopause 11 years on
and voyager 2 passed through this area
as well to come into interstellar space
to stay but what did the last planet
seem by voyager 2
look like many of you will certainly
agree that neptune rates is practically
the most mysterious planet in the solar
system
it is a body closest to uranus in terms
of its composition
it is perceived as a huge blue planet as
a rule
and has even classified as an icy giant
neptune's atmosphere is similar to that
of jupiter
and is mainly composed of hydrogen and
helium
the planetary interior is for the most
part made up of stone and dice
the color blue comes from methane in the
outer layers of the atmosphere
neptune's diameter earns it the fourth
place among the other planets of the
solar system
and it holds the third place in terms of
its mass
this planet is 17 times the size of the
earth
neptune is also known for its dire
climate
the strongest winds in the solar system
blow in its atmosphere
and according to some estimates their
speed may reach
600 meters per second a wind of this
force would append any object of average
size
landed on the planet's surface the
temperature on the surface of neptune
is close to minus 220 degrees
celsius but if you were to find yourself
there
the cold and fierce wind would not be
the most trying audio
what is much scarier is that one year on
neptune would cost you 165 earth years
since the time neptune was discovered in
just over a year has passed on this
planet
so what could voyager 2 see around that
cheerless place
the first pictures taken by voyager 2 as
it was approaching neptune
were received on the 23rd of january
when the probe was 310 million
kilometers away from the planet as the
probe got closer
the images revealed formations in
neptune's atmosphere
these three images were received at a
90-minute interval
the photos allowed scientists to see
atmospheric clouds as well as notice a
huge
dark spot
the size of the spot was similar to the
great red spot on jupiter
it should be noted that this area on
neptune was 10 percent darker than the
atmosphere surrounding it
when voyager 2 got closer still it was
able to see the planet
in color these photos were taken from
the distance of 176 million kilometers
there was a five-hour difference between
them during which time the planet had
rotated 100 degrees
the probe's next objective was the
closest satellites
on july the 3rd 1989 it was able to take
a picture of triton
and capture both triton and neptune in
one image
the probe kept getting closer and
launched another active series of
picture taking
35 million kilometers away from neptune
to capture the nebulae for closer study
apart from the great dark spot a few
dozens of similar formations were
observed
in this contrasting image voyager 2
managed to capture thin
and bright clouds this picture made it
clear
that they floated much higher than the
great dark spot
the next couple of photos was taken at a
17-hour interval
and it could be seen that the great dark
spot completed the almost full turn
around the planet
the scientists realized that spots like
these
are able to move around neptune at the
speed of a hundred meters per second
the voyage's images also made it
possible to gauge the wind force
which in some areas reached as much as
700 meters per second
which is practically the sound speed
the closest distance of the probe's
approach to the cloud layer of the
planet
made it 4 900 kilometers
the images depict cirrus clouds casting
their shadows on the layer of continuous
clouds underneath
during its flight voyager 2 was able to
take pictures of several satellites
for example triton and narrate having
done that
the probe continued on its course and
bid its last
farewell to the views of this planet the
last image taken by voyager 2 near
neptune
does indeed look like a goodbye the
probe had entered a shadow at the time
that is why just part of the icy giant
can be seen
that was the end of their short
acquaintance and voyager 2
left those parts never to return again
voyager 2 still remains the only
spacecraft to have reached uranus and
neptune
its successful mission was outstripped
only by that of the new horizons probe
which reached pluto in july 2015.
voyager 2 however will always remain a
legend of space exploration
in about 300 years it will reach the
oort cloud
and will sail beyond it only in 30 000
years
it is highly likely that by that time
more than one exploration mission to
neptune will have been launched
but the achievements of voyager 2 can
truly be called
a worthy beginning of this story
things concealed by the stars nearest to
us
will attract scientists amateur
astronomers and science fiction writers
from the earth for decades
if not centuries to come
ways to gauge the magnitude of the
universe differ from each other
but it is generally true to assume that
the solar system
stretches in all directions as far as
one light year from the sun
beyond that frontier just a few light
years away from the earth
there are the stars closest to us the
closest
out of approximately 200 billion of
those in the milky way
every star is an exploding hydrogen ball
resembling our sun and each of them
is unique the sun
the basis of our system is the closest
star to the earth unlike other stars
it is clearly visible in broad daylight
as for other celestial bodies in the
infinite space
they can be seen in the night time
however stars differ in terms of their
real brightness
scientists have defined the closest
celestial bodies within the radius of 16
light years
57 stellar systems have been pinpointed
but only seven of them can be seen in
the sky without any optical assistance
these are serious alpha centauri
epsilon
epsilon indy tau city
and 61 cygni
some of them are not just solitary
bodies but
binary or triple stars so the overall
number of these celestial bodies reaches
64.
13 brown dwarf stars are also included
in the list
they are considerably lighter than the
other bodies
proxima centauri is our closest neighbor
of all
which is 500 times less bright than the
sun
it is one of those secretive ones that
are invisible to the naked eye
that could be the reason why this object
was discovered
only in 1915 it is the third
and actually smallest stellar component
in the alpha centauri system
in contrast to the sun which finds its
way around the galaxy on its own
proxima centauri is locked in its orbit
stretching for one million years around
the two other stars
this couple known as alpha centauri a
and b is perceived as one star by the
observer on the earth who isn't
employing telescopes or binoculars
besides it is one of the brightest
systems in the sky
both stars in the system resemble the
sun much
more than proxima itself proxima's color
is completely different from that of the
sun
because this star is much colder 2700
degrees
celsius as opposed to 5500 degrees
on the sun alpha centauri a
is one and a half times brighter than
the sun and their surface temperature is
almost identical
in contrast alpha centauri b is two
times weaker than the sun
and about 500 degrees colder
interestingly in august 2016 scientists
announced the discovery of a planet the
size of the earth
going around proxima centauri
this new object known as proxima b
is about 1.3 earth masses
which according to scientists may mean
that this exoplanet
is a rocky world its location in
relation to the star makes it habitable
it is the correct distance away from the
star for water to accumulate on its
surface
proxima b is 7.5 million kilometers away
from its star
and it is likely that it's blocked that
is it faces the star by one on the same
side
just like the moon which shows the earth
only one of its parts
by the same token it's worth mentioning
that according to scientific estimates
it would take a spaceship from the earth
about
70 000 years to reach proxima centauri
however with the data received with
modern telescopes
it is still not clear whether proxima b
may be habitable speaking about the next
of our closest
stars it's another red dwarf barnard's
star
which unfortunately isn't clearly
visible either
however it is the fourth nearest star
after proxima centauri and before land
and is located in a completely different
direction
namely in the constellation of ophiuchus
and 1.7 light years further than proxima
this little star is considerably smaller
than the sun
being only 0.17 of its mass
and diameter
in fact it was discovered comparatively
recently
even though it's the fastest moving star
in the sky
crossing the distance equal to the
diameter of the full moon
in 180 years the flying barnard
is notable for its rapidity of movement
it moves towards the sun
and eventually it is going to be closer
to us than proxima centauri
the color of the star is the direct
indicator of the temperature on its
surface
just like a metal rod which when heated
first turns red
then orange after that yellow then white
and finally blue for decades
californian scientists have been making
great
efforts to discover planets in the
vicinity of barnard's star
but so far there are no data as to their
existence
here is another cluster of brown dwarfs
the constellation of velar
or sails located in the southern
hemisphere
this constellation is our second closest
star
after the sun interestingly
it is difficult to observe from the
territory of eurasia
you can see only part of it in the
southern regions of russia
and the more to the south you are the
higher the chances to observe the
constellation
by the way the best conditions for
observing at least
some parts of it are in february
speaking about the stars of this
constellation the brightest one should
be mentioned first
gamma velorum it is also nicknamed the
spectral gem of southern skies for its
rays
which boasts incredibly bright emission
lines as opposed to dark absorption
lines
which are generally more common that is
the reason for the rather exotic
spectrum
of the gamma star
800 light years away from us this star
is the second largest in the
constellation and is made up of at least
six components
also gamma 2 velorum is also generally
considered rather bright
it includes several stars one of which
belongs to the wolf riot set of stars
but these aren't all the massive bodies
in the velar constellation
for example the mass of the lumen 16
system is 30 jupiter masses with its
brightness flaring up
and fading from time to time it is
almost
7 light years away from us at the same
time
the mass of another component of lumen
equals 50 jupiter masses this
binary stellar system was discovered
comparatively recently
in 2013 while no celestial bodies or
exoplanets
have been discovered in its vicinity
[Music]
most people perceive it as one single
star
however in reality sirius is a binary
stellar system
consisting of two space objects sirius a
and series b both stars orbit around
their common gravity center at a
distance of approximately 20
astronomical units
just to compare this is only one
astronomical unit more than the distance
from uranus to the sun
their orbital period around the gravity
center is 50 years
sirius a is the main component
it is a visible star of spectral type a1
which has long been perceived as the
only star in the system
it is about two sun masses with the
radius exceeding that of the sun by 71
percent
due to its close proximity sirius a is
one of the easiest objects for amateur
astronomers
the star is 8.6 light years away from
our system
and its brightness is 25 times as
intense as that of the sun
in addition to its superiority over our
main star in terms of its dimensions and
mass
this celestial object also beats it in
the temperature level
which may reach 9940 kelvins on its
surface
as opposed to only 5778 kelvins on the
sun
the most exciting peculiarity of the
object is a high level of iron in its
atmosphere
which is 316 percent as abundant as on
the sun
also the spectrum shows that other
elements heavier than helium are to be
found
the star is likely to have been enriched
in metallic elements
tens of millions of years ago by a
neighboring object
speaking about its future evolution
sirius a will probably
continue to exist as it is for another
600 million years or so
after which it will turn into a red
giant
and then a white dwarf even though
only several thousand white dwarfs are
known to science today
this kind of final state is typical of
stars relatively similar to our sun in
terms of dimensions and mass
these objects are hard to discover which
has to do with their low luminosity and
small diameter
however according to scientists their
overall number in our galaxy is
estimated to reach
10 billion that is about five percent of
all stars in the milky way
the second component of the serious
stellar system is exactly one of such
objects
which is the first white dwarf to have
been discovered
as far back as in 1844 the famous german
astronomer friedrich bessel noticed
that the trajectory of serious a from
time to time deviates from its linear
motion
bessel accounted for this behavior by
suggesting the existence of a hidden
mass
orbiting together with a star around a
common center
this hypothesis caused a lot of
skepticism for if it held good
the mass of the latent satellite was
supposed to equal that of our sun
nevertheless 18 years later in january
basil's assumptions proved to be true
while testing a new 46 centimeter
refractor
the american astronomer alvin graham
clark cited a tiny star near sirius
its orbital movement corresponded to
friedrich vessel's calculations
the star was dubbed serious b
this object is the heaviest white dwarf
of all known to science
and has approximately the mass of the
sun but even in spite of this indicator
not typical of this celestial object's
variety
its volume accounts for less than one
millionth of that of the sun
and its dimensions are mystique those of
the earth
before becoming a white dwarf the star
is likely to have completed the two
basic stages of star
evolution the main sequence stage
and then the red giant stage scientists
believe that the process of turning into
a white dwarf took place approximately
120 million years ago
and the star's mass used to be five
times that of the sun
at this moment sirius b is barely
luminous
with its luminosity being 0.026 that of
the sun
and with an exceptionally high
temperature of 25
200 kelvins on its surface
as sirius b has no internal heat source
it will gradually cool off and will
eventually become a hypothetical black
dwarf in over 2 billion years time
however this kind of objects hasn't been
cited by scientists yet
unlike its younger neighbor this star
isn't easily observable in our sky
which is the reason why sirius b has
long been inadvertently ignored by
science
only on october the 15th 2003 did
scientists receive a clearer image of
the object
with the help of the hubble telescope
both stars are visible in this picture
sirius a
the brighter one and sirius b the tiny
one
the object is located in the well-known
constellation canis major in the
southern hemisphere of the sky
but it is visible to the naked eye in
the northern hemisphere as well
due to its perfect visibility sirius has
been studied by mankind for a great
number of years
getting shrouded by an increasing number
of legends
as far back as an ancient egypt the
object was referred to as the nile star
and was associated with the name of the
goddess subdead
as its morning rise heralded the river
flooding during the summer solstice
sirius is mentioned in the works of the
roman scientists
sunica and ptolemy who described the
star as scarlet
the object also holds a place in the
history of mesopotamian and chinese
astronomy
it is also characteristically referred
to as a bright red star
due to such conflicting descriptions
sirius became notorious for being the
object of manifold's pseudo-scientific
theories
the temporary reddening of the star can
be explained by the influence of
interstellar dust which for a while came
between
sirius and the earth with the effect of
giving the radiance a reddish hue
another explanation could line the
possibility of there being a third
component in the system
whose orbital period equals about two
thousand years
when in close proximity to series a
this hypothetical celestial object could
cause the star to flush red
nonetheless to date nothing even faintly
resembling this kind of object has been
discovered
in april 2018 nasa launched the
transiting exoplanet survey satellite
tess with the aim of finding exoplanets
orbiting bright stars
due to the fact that sirius is a young
star it is rather unlikely that any
planets will be discovered in its
environs
but the satellite will collect data that
will facilitate its investigation
in more detail even if there is at least
one big planet in this system life
cannot be sustained there
as too little time has passed since the
formation of the star itself
apart from that any planets within the
habitable zone must have been burned out
when serious beer was in its red dwarf
stage and as a result there is as good
as no chance of discovering
any life forms in this system
sirius is likely to be a relatively
young system according to modern
estimates as well
its age gauged as being between 200 to
300 million years
procyon is the closest star to sirius
being 5.2 light years away
the sun holds the sixth place on this
list
although this may well change in the
future
the point is that sirius approaches our
system
at the speed of 7.6 kilometers per
second
which is why its brightness visible to
us is going to gradually
sirius will remain the brightest star in
our sky for thousands of years to come
after which the process is supposed to
be reversed
with the star growing ever dimmer to the
observer on our earth
in our modern age some may think
astronomy to be a young science
as most discoveries are being made with
the use of state-of-the-art equipment
however the movements of celestial
bodies have been studied throughout the
entire history of mankind
and the star sirius is a perfect
confirmation of this
[Music]
the statement that there are boundaries
to the universe is considered per se
one of those great ideas which are able
to dramatically change our world
perception
something similar took place back in
when nicholas copernicus proved that the
earth wasn't located in the center of
the cosmos
the following breakthrough took place in
the 20th century
when edwin hubble showed to the world
that galaxies moved away from each other
this prompted the idea that the universe
hasn't existed eternally
and was formed as a result of a certain
event
the big bang today we are certain that
the dimensions of the world we live in
are much larger than we are capable of
imagining
the search for the answer to the
question about its boundaries
is going to lead to yet another
scientific breakthrough
at the moment scientists are able to
talk only of the boundaries
within which the objects are visible
this area is also called the observable
universe
that is its part which is the absolute
past in relation to the observer
the cosmic horizon is the boundary of
the observable universe
the objects on the horizon become
infinitely red-shifted
that is they constantly move further
away
the number of galaxies within the
observable universe is estimated at
upwards of 500 billion
with this number increasing on a regular
basis
as the research equipment becomes more
advanced
but how big is the observable area of
the universe today
the distance to the remotest observable
objects equals approximately 14 billion
parsecs
in all directions thus the observable
universe is a sphere
with a diameter of about 93 billion
light years
and with the center inside the solar
system
that is it is centered on the observer
the area equals 305 quin vigentillion
cubic meters
it should be mentioned that the light
emitted by the further most observable
objects
has been traveling for 13.8 billion
light years
before reaching us however the distance
to those objects has significantly grown
due to the never ceasing expansion of
the universe
this process is the result of there
being matter and energy in space
filling space-time
while there is matter in space there is
gravitational force
therefore the universe either shrinks
affected by gravity
or expands affected by dark energy
it is also worth noting that there isn't
a single center for the universe's
expansion
just like there isn't a space for the
universe to expand into
beyond its boundaries this process takes
place with the mata in space
at any point everywhere and at all times
we do not physically perceive this as
the force holding our atoms and
molecules together
does not allow us to burst under the
influence of the space expansion
this may be compared to a baking loaf of
bread
with the raisins for galaxies and
similar formations
and the dough for the space matter
according to estimates the distance to
the furthermost observable objects today
equals approximately 14 giga parsecs
or 46 billion light years
the furthermost stellar system with
respect to the earth is a galaxy
dubbed gnz11 its light has been
traveling to us for about
13.4 billion years
meaning that this object was formed less
than 400 million years
after the big bang however
due to the constant expansion of the
universe today's distance to gnz11 is
approximately
32 billion light years
one may argue that the speed with which
it recedes exceeds the speed of light
but it does not clash with a special
theory of relativity
as it isn't the matter that is receding
but the space
between the two objects is growing
larger
this object is supposedly one of the
very first galaxies
and is likely to be the closest stellar
cluster
to the edge of the observable universe
if man were able to freely travel from
one world to another
it is in that galaxy that we might find
out about the genesis of our world
in more detail what we call the meta
galaxy
is likely to have started to expand
immediately on its birth
in theory the boundaries of the meta
galaxy may well reach the cosmic
singularity
that is it may show us what the world
had been like before the big bang
but in practice it is relic radiation
that is the limit to the observable
it is this radiation that is emitted by
the furthermost object in the universe
to have been observed in contemporary
science
this radiation poses something like a
barrier for our vision
it came about approximately 380
000 years after the big bang that is at
the time when the universe
cooled off sufficiently for atoms to
emerge
in plain english it is similar to an
image of space
in its childhood where it is depicted
before the formation of the first stars
it is likely that the universe stretches
infinitely beyond this barrier
and it is there that its hypothetical
boundaries are to be found
the objects beyond this barrier are
referred to in a number of ways
multiverse objects parallel universe
objects to name the two
science today is incapable of defining
these bodies with any detail
however assuming that the universe
carries on expanding
we may conclude that the objects we're
able to observe
now are sooner or later going to
disappear from our field of vision
if the accelerating expansion of the
universe continues indefinitely
the galaxies beyond our supercluster are
sooner or later going to recede beyond
the horizon as a result
thus becoming invisible to us any form
of communication beyond the boundaries
of the observable universe will be
rendered impossible
and any contact between the objects will
be lost
the earth the solar system the milky way
and our supercluster
will be mutually observable whereas the
rest of the universe will recede in the
distance
there may be hypothetical worlds beyond
the regions observable to us
they originate as a result of phase
transitions of physical vacuum
alternatively there may be objects
forming out of irregularities of relic
radiation
located closest to the particle horizon
the question of multiverse objects
remains a bone of contention among
scientists
prompting an overwhelming number of
pseudo-scientific guesses
be it as it may most researchers see eye
to eye
as to the infinity of our universe
although they interpret it in different
ways
some of them claim our world to be
multi-dimensional
which makes our three-dimensional
universe merely one of its
layers others are inclined to believe in
the theory of a multi-universe
with us as a minuscule fraction of an
infinite multitude
whereas there may be a portal to other
worlds beyond the observable area of the
universe
some space theories involve the
existence of the so-called event horizon
according to this concept we're never
going to be able to look beyond the
event horizon
because the speed at which photons
travel away from us
will be higher than the speed with which
the observable universe
expands according to this theory
all the galaxies surrounding us are
bound to recede
beyond the event horizon it will look
like
time stopped in them we will observe
them
infinitely receding beyond the
observable boundaries
but never quite disappearing from view
be it as it may contemporary science
cannot provide a definite answer to this
question
although the situation may change
overnight once we have developed
more advanced observation equipment the
universe might turn out to be a sort of
sphere
and traveling over it might remind one
of travelling on the spherical surface
of our earth
considering the scale it reaches however
this prospect
appears impossible in order to reach the
edge of the observable universe
it would take man 46 billion years
even if we travel at the speed of light
by the time we reached this designated
point it would have moved the same
distance away
and a similar journey would have to be
embarked upon
it is likely that there aren't any large
objects beyond the observable universe
and on peering there we would see just a
homogeneous cloud of helium
hydrogen and a few other elements
however we might probably never be able
to discover the origins of our world
and might forever remain in the position
of someone
chasing the horizon what we have just
covered
is only a tiny part of the vast expanses
of space
it may take humans more than one
millennium to explore the rest of it
however with the rapidity of the pace at
which science
strides forward it is safe to say that
every scientific breakthrough
will exponentially facilitate our
progress and who knows
sooner or later we might get to the
point when the universe will be explored
with the same precision
as the surface of our own planet
[Music]
you